Transcriber: Arda Akgül
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Bir bedene daha veririz.
Anne karnında yumuşak, korunaklı bir
havuzun içindeyken aniden ağırlığımızı
hissettiğimiz bir deneyimi
yaşama geliyoruz.
Hepimiz biliyoruz ki yaşamak
çok da kolay değil.
Birçok zorluğu beraberinde getiriyor.
Kendi hayatımıza dair kayıplarımız var,
kitlesel kayıplarımız var, başka canlara
dair kayıplar var.
Peki?
Yaşam.
Sürekli bu yenilgi hissini
kabul ettiğimiz.
Öğrenilmiş şekillerde hareket ettiğimiz.
Kendini tekrar eden, farkında olmadan
sürekli birilerinin bir şeylerin yasını
tuttuğumuz bir döngü.
Tüm bu acı ve yok oluş içerisinde
nasıl çiçek açabiliriz?
Ve tüm bu acıyı ve yok oluş içerisinde
açan çiçeği nasıl görebiliriz?
Ben kendim için çiçeği görebildiğim
bir alan yarattım.
Görmekle kalmıyorum.
Bazen o çiçeğe dönüşüyor, bazen
kokusu bile gerçek oluyor.
Bugün size bu alandan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Çok güzel olan şey de bu alanın sadece
bana ait değil, herkese ait olması.
Yani gitmenin yollarını bulursak
bu yer hepimiz için.
Tek başınıza da düşebiliriz, birlikte de.
Ayrıca başında söylediğim gibi
bir bedene doğru yürüyoruz.
Ama bu yere gitmek için nasıl bir bedene
de olduğumuzun da hiçbir önemi yok.
Ben burada kendimi eleştirdim.
Gerçek dönüşümler yaşadım.
Başka insanların kendileriyle ilgili
deli keşiflerini tanık oldum.
Bazen alan açtım.
Ben kendi yolumun yanlış kalmakla,
sorular sormakla ve hareket
etmekle buldum.
Geldiğim yeri anlatmak için size biraz
aşina bahsetmek istediğim şey.
Buraya nasıl geldiğim.
Benim doğduğum alan iyileşmek
üzerineydi
ve annem ve babam doktor.
O yüzden hastanede çok zaman geçirdim.
Oranın kokusu, beyaz koridorları,
floresan ışıkları beni çok etkilerdi.
Bu klinik ortamın yanı sıra
doğada çok zaman geçirdim.
Ormanla oynayalım, kumda, çamurda
resim yapardım, şiir yazardım.
Belki camimizin içten yaptığı şeyler ama
benim için bir yanlar olan önemsiz
imamlar anlattı.
Daha sonra ilkokul 5'te babaannemin ve
dedemin yanına ilkokul okumaya gittiğinde
ilk kadınının aniden yumruk
yiyeceğim bir yer.
Yeni insanlar.
Kimseyi tanımıyorum sanki.
O kimliğin o kısmı değersiz değişmişti.
İçi boşalmıştı.
Tekrar güven inşa etmem gerekecekti.
Yaptım da.
Dansın çok büyük bir etkisi oldu.
Dostlukları oldu.
Hala benim için çok değerli olan,
ben değiştiren, dönüştüren.
Kendi bedenim değişti.
Baktım ki ailem dönüştü.
Ben sonunda etkisi var.
Baktım ki aslında.
Olduğunu kat genişledikçe ben de kabın
içerisine genişleyebiliyorum..
Yani Samsun’dan Ankara, yepyeni bir yer.
Ben de buranın içerisinde büyüyebiliyorum.
Hareketlerim de büyüyebiliyor.
Bu sırada bir dans yarışmasını kazandım.
Yarışmayla dünyayı gezmeye başladım.
Yeni yerler gördüm ve tekrar,
daha da büyüyebilir.
Her şey daha da büyük olabilir.
O zaman daha büyük hayal kurabilirim.
Geriye dönüp baktığımda onu
fark ediyorum aslında.
Belki bir kere daha o kabın
büyüyebileceğini görmüş olmak ve onun
için daha büyük hayaller kurmaya
yardımcı olmuştu.
21 yaşında Londra'ya taşındım okumak için.
Sonra orada kaldım ve zor
bir olasılık oldu.
Bir sürü kayıp yaşadığımız sırada.
Ve farkettim ki Aslı’nın 20 senedir
kurduğu kimlik bir kere daha sıfırlanmış.
Kimseyi tanımıyorum.
Yerli ve yabancı olduğum bir
ülkede yemek ve dans o.
Kendine inşa ettiğin kişinin, ABD'nin
bile burada tam olarak çevirisi yok.
O yüzden dedim ki Ekin daha derine inmiş.
Dansın ötesinde ne var?
Senin için dansın ötesinde ne var?
Sorular sordum.
Yatakta uzun süre kendi
kendime konuşurdum.
Soru cevap yazardım.
Ben şunu sordum kendime Sen kimsin?
Burada olmanın nasıl bir önemi var?
Ne yapman lazım hayatta?
Fark ettim ki ben başka insanlara
da yardımcı olmak istiyorum.
Daha sonra ötesinde benim için bu vardı.
Bu sırada dans terapisini öğrendim.
Dans terapisi bir yöntem.
Birey ile terapistin, bedenin sanatı,
dansı, hareketi bir iletişim aracı
olarak kullanıldığı güvenli
bir alan yarattınız.
Teke, tek ya da grup olarak
çalışılabilecek bir metot.
Baktım ki bu güzel güzel kadınlardan
hoşlanmıyorum ve tanımlamaktan.
Ama bunu kendime söylemekten
korkmam diye düşündüm.
Dans terapisti.
Bu sefer yeni bir kimlik atılacaktı.
Şimdi ilk 25 senesine iki paragrafta
özetlediğimiz hayatının son 10 senesine
gelecek olursak.
Her şey biraz ithamlar kazanmaya başladı.
Son geldiğim oda içerisinde.
Bir bütün olduğunu hissediyorum.
Daha yakın olduğumu hissediyorum
ve bütün olmaya.
Bu yerde önce klinik tarafı
anlatmak istiyorum.
Klinik olarak çalışmaya başladım.
Otizmli çocuklarda şizofreni tanısı olan
yetişkinlerden başka bir sürü sebepten
toplum tarafından ötekileştirilmiş
zorluklar yaşamış insanlarla çalışma
şansım oldu.
Olmaya devam ediyor.
Çok fazla şey öğreniyorum.
Sürekli gelişmekte gereken bir alan.
Ama şunu fark ettim ki sanat
aslında sadece estetiğin.
Üretimin olduğu bir yer değil.
Aslında duygularımızı geliştirebileceğini
ve başkalarına da duygularını
dönüştürmeleri için alana çekeceğimiz yer
belirli insanlara ait değil hepimiz için.
Mesela savaş yüzünden ülkesini kaybetmiş
çocuklarla ayakkabı kutularının içerisine
evler yaptığımızda, sonra bunlardan bir
şehir oluşturup geriye dönüp baktığımızda.
Geçmişle gelecek arasında oldukları
yerler ve bulundukları.
Belki de yersizdir üzerine konuşabilmek.
Benim için büyük kapılar açtı,
içinde farklılıklar yarattı.
Ya da kelimeleri kullanamayan bir çocukla
haftada değil aylarca yaptığımız
çalışmalar üzerine yarattığımız
güvenli ortamla.
Onun bize güven duymasını ve kendini ifade
etmeye başlaması iletişimin sadece
kelimelerle olmayacağını gösterdi.
Ya da Ben asla adamı sevemem, dans etmem
diyen birisinin hastanede yaşadıklarını
anlattıktan sonra ayağa kalkıp dans
edişini alan açmış olmak, onunla yaşamak.
Bir sahnede binlerce kişinin önünde dans
etmekle benzer bir sevgiyi çıkarıp benim
içimde her ikisini de yaşadım
ve deneyimden konuşuyorum.
Çok farklı varoluş şekilleri gibi
görünüyor ama aslında özünde aynı şey var.
Yine aynı şeyi söylemek istiyorum.
Eğer gözlerinizi kapayıp, alanı açıp
kendinize soruları sorarsanız, sizin
içinizden de o sanatçılar.
Buna paralel olarak.
Bir de o içimdeki sanatçının bazı soruları
ve ifade etmek istediği şeyler
vardı.
O yüzden kendim devrettim
ve hayatı anlamlı bir şekilde
anlamaya çalıştım.
Kendim için zorlandığım anlarda kayıpların
olduğunda bir şey benim canımı
acıttığını hep sonunda kendime
yüklendim.
Mesela orman yangınları olduğunda şiir
yazarak kendimi sakinleştirdi.
Ormana da sürekli gidiyorum ve
geçiriyorsanız herkese çok tavsiye ederim.
Düzenli oraya gitmelisiniz.
Bizim için çok iyi bir yer.
Görüşmeyle ilgili kaygılarım olduğunda
evleri istediğim bir performans yaptım.
Herkesten ses kayıtları topladık
ve anlamaya çalıştık.
En önemlisi.
Kalbim kırıldığında kayıplar yaşadım
da bedenimi hazırladım.
Sonra bu ağaçlardan heykeller yaptım.
Pandev olduğunda kendimi bir paraşütle
bağladım ve bu havada asılı kalma
hayattaki kayıp olduğumuz yerle
ilgili hepimiz için
bir şeyler söylemeye çalıştım.
Yolun kaybettiğinde ve kararsız kaldığında
28 gün boyunca bir odada
insanlara “Ne istiyorsun?”
sorusunu sorduk.
Aldığımız 900'ün üzerindeki
cevabı duvarlara astık.
Son performansında ise ölüme baktım.
Belki de yaşadığımız kayıplar yüzünden
geçtiğimiz senelerde etrafta
çok ölüm görüyorum.
Bu araştırma sırasında karşıma
sevgili e-kitap çıktı.
Sevgili Özerkan, Aydın’da bir mermerin
kazılı olarak bulunmuş.
Dünyanın bilinen en eski
müzik kompozisyonu
ve Aydın da bulunmuş.
Sözleri şöyle hem sözleri
var hem melodisi var.
Melodiyi şu an çalmayacak
ama sözleri şu şekilde.
Yaşarken parlak hiçbir korkun olmasın.
Hayat çok kısa bir süre için var
ve zaman alacağını alır.
Yani baktım ki
ben ölüme bakıyorum ve benim
karşıma yaşam çıkıyor.
Her seferinde her yerime baktığımda
kendimi bu şekilde dönüştürdüğü, benim
elimde şekli değişmiş bambaşka
bir kabuk kaldı.
O yüzden diyorum ki yaralarımızı
hala bakarsak.
Yarının ötesinde neler olur?
Çünkü bu yer öyle bir yer ki orada.
Buradan farklı şeyler var.
Orası tam olarak burası değil.
Orada barış bir hayal değil.
Biz daha birbirimize benzeriz.
Her şeyi kutulara koyarak
anlamaya çalışıyoruz.
Yeni dünya düzeninde bir şeyleri kategorik
kategorilere ayırmak bizim
dünyayı anlama şeklimiz oldu.
Kendimize benzemeyen her şeye
kartla yaklaşıyoruz.
Ayrıldık, yalnız ulaştık, uzaklaştık.
Bedenlerimiz arasına ciddi
bir mesafe girdi.
Yüzümüzün yarısı görülmez oldu.
Yuvalar, ilişkiler, evler dönüştür.
Şimdi biz bu yaraya tekrar bakmak
istersek, bize söylemek istediği başka
şeyler olabilir mi?
Benim inancım Işıl hareket dönüştürür.
Sanat dönüştürür.
İletişimin farklı yolları vardır
ve bunu tekrar söylemek istiyorum.
Sadece bana veya bunu yapmayı seçmiş
insanlara ait değil, herkese ait bir şey.
Bunu kültürümüze geri getirmemiz
gerektiğine inanıyorum ve bunun
için çalışıyorum.
Sizi bu alana çağırmak istiyorum.
Zamanı genişletmek için.
Yaşadığımız hissetmek, kendini özgür
hissetmek için hayatın kutsallığını,
büyüsünü hatırlamak için,
oyunu oynamak için.
Dans ederek
Yanınıza koşuyorum, bunu paylaşın.
İnanıyorum ki sizin içinizde de yeni
odalar, yeni yollar, yeni kapılar, yeni
sorular açılacak, çıkacak.
Belki de yeni bir sistem var
anlayışının altında.
Babaannemin söylediğine göre, ilk
konuşmayı öğrendiğim yıllarda yazındaki
balkonundan aşağı sarık, oradan geçenlere
Sen kimsin, nereye gidiyorsun?
Diye sorar mısın?
Cevap da herhalde çok belirli şeylerdir.
Bakkala veya deyince gibi ihtimaller var.
Bu çok önemli değil ama soru önemli.
Dedim ya.
Şimdi buradayım.
Kendime soruyorum ilkin Sen kimsin,
nereye gidiyorsun?
İçimde çok yoğun bir üretme isteği var.
Yaşadığımız bu zorlukların kökünde
iki sevgi eksikliğini,
şefkat eksikliğini görüyorum.
Bunu değiştirmek için elimden
geleni yapmaya çalışıyorum.
Bir şeyler üretip dünyayı
gezmeye çalışıyorum.
Ben de iş gücünün peşinden gidiyorum.
Sevgiyi yaymaya çalışıyorum
aslında özünde.
Şu an hatırlanması isterim.
Çünkü bir soru gerçekten her
şeyi değiştirebilecek.
Uzun bir masada otururken birisinin
söylediği şarkı, yol,
gittiğimiz yer var ya.
Benim için tüm cevaplar, tüm sorular orda
ya da balkonun aşağı sarkan bir çocuğu
meraklı bana bakıp sorduklarında.
Peki sen kimsin?
Nereye gidiyorsun? Teşekkürler.